we've so far been thinking about
coordinates coordinates
that's like here the point just one
here's another point just one by itself
but sometimes you actually don't just
want one point you want a collection of
points so it's like how B can be a whole
bunch of different places so instead of
representing a point source points are
represented with coordinate we don't use
coordinates when we want to represent an
entire line does anyone know that we
actually use we use line what you want
is a connection between our Y and an ex
some kind of combination of values right
so we use the equation the business and
I hope this is ringing a bell from last
year you know how we've got an X and a
y-axis so as an example eg I could say y
equals 2x so this is an equation in two
x's it's got wires in it and I can
represent a wide with it let's represent
that line together just to refresh your
memory
if you've got your axes set up what this
means is this is all the points where
the Y value is class of B to the XL and
you can achieve that at this point for
example if the x value will stay out of
it one what would the wide open it'll be
double that which is to prepare bless
you if the x value were three
what would the Y value in it will be
twice the science which is six
what if you x value will sewer well
twice 0 is still 0 okay now you can keep
on doing this forever but the point is
we control a line that represents all
these together without any constantly
winding point after point I just to take
these guys impossible
my actions here zero zero like make one
two there and then there we go so this
line represents the equation and the
equation represents one they're kind of
like two sides of the same coin because
this line is this equation I actually
legal
as such I say that line is y equals 2x
or the equation of that line is y equals
2x you can put all kinds of equations
onto there so for instance how to look
back to this question we did just now
how long did you work out what the
equation of this line is you know some
point on there there's 3 comma 1
there's 7 comma 3 how could you work out
a pattern that links them together
let me help you out do you remember I
said to you this question here it
doesn't like it if you don't you just
try and put in a formula it doesn't play
well with that well you still can watch
this we'll hear what is great in again
it's a it's like everyone which in this
particular case is one over two it's a
hot one right so the gradient a B is a
hot right but you know what a is it's 3
comma 1 right so I can write rise
everyone like this the rise is some Y
value take away 1 rise they're over some
x value take away 3 that's the run key
I'm comparing wives with y's and x's
with X's what do you do this I want to
write a bit of a mystery now how can I
simplify this a little bit
any suggestions I can cross-multiply you
guys you've seen that before right I can
multiply to everything by 2 so that
leaves me with 2 y -2 over there and
then I'll multiply everything by X minus
3 as well as these movies that this is
an equation this equation is this wine
watch let me tie it up pertaining a
little bit let's see it let's write it
as 2 y minus X plus 1 doesn't check out
isn't the same appraisers do you see I
subtracted x from both sides subtract X
from both sides and then what else did I
do I added 3 to both sides
so that's why it's plus 1 are you ok
resent me now look this equation is this
line 2 y minus X plus 1 equals 0
let me check that sire suggested the
0.73 is on here so if x equals 3 let's
see what happens when I throw it in
- why - three three that's what you're
just suggesting two plus one equals zero
y 1/3 X like you said you guys can catch
it I'm introspective no news okay it's
actually at seven right do you say seven
you're reading a Y point at rather next
corner can you simplify that for me what
happens what's minus 7 plus 1 is minus 6
right can you simplify again what else
matters onion and 6 both sides what
right and y equals women it better be
because Allah told me it was right
beside Chile right so you see every
single point on this line you can put in
x equals 3 and you'll get why cause
nearer it's all going to work out it's
already phenomenal why does one sorry
don't do it important so here's my point
that you use coordinates if you want to
my points use equations if you want to
talk about - you just take your equation
is try and some values out and you get
the set of points on that one okay